well after one extraordinary year what
are the chances we have another one
let's look at some of the charts that we
might be talking about over the course
of the next 12 months starting with this
one we're already talking about it
actually aren't we gas prices this is
wholesale gas prices feeds into our
bills eventually but here's something
interesting you might have noticed this
because we reported on it uh the UK's
gas prices wholesale gas prices actually
for much of 2022 were lower than the
prices that you saw in North Europe
but here's what's interesting we might
over the course of the next few months
see that reversing so the UK may have to
pay higher prices for gas higher
wholesale prices for gas feeds into the
prices for all of the rest of us then
Europe why because we have less storage
and if it gets cold you kind of need
that storage so that's one thing to look
out for as is this waiting list NHS
waiting list that they've been creeping
up in 2022 you can see them by different
lengths of time that people have been
waiting up to over 7 million in total in
the third quarter of 2022. now here's
the bad news that is expected that
Mountain's expected to get even higher
over uh 2023 and it may not even Peak
until 2024 so we're still likely to be
talking about a crisis in the NHS for
that and for many other reasons
unfortunately for quite some time now
the next thing it's a slightly
complicated chart but it really matters
because what have we learned from 2022
it is that the guilts market where the
government borrows were issues those
bonds those ious it's really important
it feeds into our lives and this is just
showing you these bars are basically
showing how much debt the government is
issuing so anything above the line is
then basically borrowing money issuing
ious
but here's what's interesting the bank
of England recently up until recently
has been buying a lot of that debt so
I'm going to show you these light blue
bars that's what the bank of England has
been buying but as of well where we are
right now and certainly the next few
years that's gone into reverse and they
are selling all of that debt back it's
called quantitative tightening it was QE
quantitative easing before now it's
quantitative tightening but the upshot
of all of this look if we net those two
things off so we add them up you see
that red line that's what the government
uh what the the private Market is having
to absorb all those Pension funds all
those Insurance funds they have to
absorb an enormous amount of money
flowing into the market over the next
few years no one knows if they're going
to be able to do that so that is a big
thing to look out for as is this of
course it has a bearing on what's
happening with interest rates this is
showing you expectations for Bank of
England interest rate we're looking back
to February 2022 and remember I mean it
feels like not that long ago but of
course people thought interest rates
weren't going up above maybe 1.5 percent
back then then you had the new
government coming in they thought well
they're going to spend more money so
that's going up up then you had the mini
budget remember that they thought wow
it's going to Peak at 6.4 percent but
then things since then have calmed down
a bit and now investors think interest
rates are going to Peak at 4.5
will that be the case will that be the
peak will it be a little bit lower we'll
find out soon it will be quite a year
though many charts many issues whether
it's Health whether it's the economy to
bring you in the coming months